reconnaissance satellite launch
this launch may have failed but it was
launched in Brazen violation of multiple
Security Council resolutions raised
tensions and risk destabilizing the
already sensitive security situation in
the region and Beyond
this Council cannot ignore the dprk's
failed launches as they allow the dprk
to learn about its capability gaps and
determine how to advance its unlawful
wmd and ballistic missile programs
accordingly
its intent borne out by action and
statements is clear
to pose a threat to International Peace
and security
the launch not only disrupted Maritime
and air traffic in the region but it
also caused alarm for its neighbors in
Japan and the Republic of Korea
colleagues
this Council has the mandate to act in
response to this repeated and aggressive
pattern of dprk violations of multiple
Security Council resolutions
and we have before specifically in
response to dprk satellite launches
in both resolutions 2087 and 2270 the
council condemned the dprk's tests of
space launch Vehicles because they use
ballistic missile technology and thus
violate the resolutions
the council reaffirmed the freedom of
all states to explore and use outer
space in accordance with international
law
the launch we saw this week however is
undeniably in violation of international
law
the dprk is now threatening to conduct
another launch
and I quote as soon as possible unquote
the dprk
with the support of its two staunch
Defenders on the council
are trying to normalize these unlawful
launches and assert they are Justified
there is nothing that provoked the dprk
to conduct this week's launch
nor to threaten another one except for
the dprk's desire to perfect its
technology that failed this week
we must not allow the unprecedented
volume of the regime's ballistic missile
launches over the past year and a half
to wear us down
the United States remains committed to
diplomacy and we continue to urge the
dprk to come to the table for Meaningful
negotiations without preconditions
but as long as Pyongyang Feels embolden
by The Silence of this Council to
dissipate Security Council resolution
obligations and seeks to undermine the
global nonproliferation regime
it will continue to choose ammunition
over nutrition
meanwhile
as Russia and China reaffirm their
commitment to a diplomatic solution
they argue that a council product or
even holding a council meeting are
provocative actions
may I remind them
that what we do here in the security
Council at least when their
obstructionism does not prevail
is diplomacy
China and Russia will likely once again
attempt to draw false equivalences
between the dprk's unlawful ballistic
missile launches and lawful defensive
and pre-announced US ROK joint military
exercises
these false equivalences simply don't
hold up under International scrutiny
our lawful efforts to defend against the
dprk's repeated escalatory actions do
not in any way justify the dprk's
unlawful Behavior
the dprk is simply using this as an
excuse
to allow the dprk to advance its
unlawful wmd and ballistic missile
programs
in the face of the growing dprk wmd and
ballistic missile threat and the council
silence
it is unbelievable that the two members
of this Council
expect the United States
and our allies to stand idly by
our commitment
to our alliances our Ironclad
and we will take all necessary measures
to ensure our security
we call on all council members
to uphold The credibility of the council
join us in condemning this unlawful
Behavior
and urge the dprk
to not follow through on its stated plan
to conduct another launch that will
further pose a threat to International
Peace and security
thank you madam president
I thank the representative of the United
States for their statement and I now
give the floor to the representative of
Albania
thank you madam president and thank you
usgd Carla for the update I will make a
few quick points
first Albania condemns strongly and
unreservedly the launch of the military
reconnaissance reconnaissance Satellite
by the dprk regime two days ago the
sixth of such attempts and the first
since 2016.
second the launch failed but it is just
another escalatory step by Pyongyang and
a Brazen violation of numerous UNC
Council resolutions I will not enumerate
them there are just too many
third with its egregious and Reckless
Behavior the dprk continues to defy
openly the U.N the security Council and
the International Community as a whole
the established norms and rules it is
only seeking provocation the
stabilization and escalation including
by announcing that it will proceed to
another launch satellite lunch soon
fourth every time the council is
prevented from taking action the regime
feels more empowered to continue on the
same path as we have seen in the course
of the last two years the recipe is
working
dprk shows only disregard and contempt
for the security Council and its
decisions more and more because it feels
protected because it is protected this
is wrong utterly wrong and it goes
against what this Council stands for
we regret that the voice of the majority
of the members of this Council calling
for a clear and strong rejection to the
illegal
reaction to the illegal unprovoked and
Reckless actions by the dprk continues
to be ignored if the council continues
to tolerate the indefensible actions of
North Korea now it will be even harder
to react and act later unless this is a
true aim we should get out immediately
of this deafening silence
colleagues we retrieve that with its
inactivity the security Council has
conveyed the war mongers in North Korea
that for them actions have no
consequences
we should not wait for the worst to
happen to do something which may prove
too little too late
because with its inactivity on the
matter the council is failing to have
dprk regime understand the limits of its
unacceptable policies and behavior it is
failing to help open an Avenue of
negotiations the only way to properly
address and contribute to solving the
crisis it is failing to reassure
neighboring countries including the
people of Japan and the Republic of
Korea and it is failing its core Duty
and responsibilities it is eroding its
credibility and it is failing finally to
explain to The Wider membership how a
continued open and defined disregard of
multiple Security Council resolutions by
the dprk is contributing in any way to
peace and security it is therefore time
to speak up to be United around enough
is enough the people of North Korea do
need do not need more weapons the region
doesn't need more provocations and the
world doesn't need more dangerous
escalations what is needed are talks
through good faith diplomacy to ensure a
full transparent comprehensive and
irreversible end of weapons of mass
destruction ballistic new tier program
only this would help North Korea become
a normal country start developing and
progressing the security Council can
help in this respect but if only if it
decides to speak with one voice and with
the United and clear response I thank
you
I thank the representative of Albania
for their statement I give the floor to
the representative of Ecuador
president
a complicated situation
Expressions
attempts to foreign
[Music]
by significant Global powers
foreign
good faith
all of those dialogues would be to
reduce and overcome pensions in the
region in the Korean Peninsula thank you
I thank the representative of Ecuador
for their statement I now give the floor
to the representative of the United
Kingdom
thank you president
the United Kingdom condemns The dprk's
Reckless failed satellite launch of 30th
of May 2023.
let's be clear
this launch had nothing to do with
peaceful uses of outer space
it was a military reconnaissance
satellite
and use ballistic missile technology to
Launch
as such it was a further violation of
this council's resolutions
this follows nine sets of ballistic
missile tests since the start of 2023
including a solid fuel into Continental
ballistic missile test in April
all parts of dprk's Reckless pursuit of
advanced nuclear and ballistic missile
capabilities
with which it seeks to threaten its
neighbors
while the launch failed it caused alarm
for the people of Japan and the Republic
of Korea
but is the north it is the North Korean
people who bear the highest costs of
these launches as their government
diverts resources away from people's
basic economic needs
colleagues this behavior is unacceptable
the dprk continues to flout the
international non-proliferation
architecture
and poses a great threat to Global Peace
and security
we understand that it didn't tend to
repeat the failed launch as soon as it
can
the United Kingdom is ready to work
urgently with all council members to
send the unified message to the dprk
we continue to urge all member states to
fully Implement existing resolutions and
to counter the continued development of
dprk's illegal weapons programs
once again President we urge the dprk to
cease these launches return to dialogue
and take credible steps towards
denuclearization and peace on the Korean
peninsula thank you
I thank the representative of the United
Kingdom for their statement I give the
floor to the representative of Japan
thank you madam president I also thank
Ms Rosemary decalo for her briefing
North Korea's series of actions
including the latest launch using
ballistic missile technology
threatened the peace and security of
Japan the region and the entire
International Community
all of these are flagrant violations of
the relevant Security Council
resolutions
Japan joins Secretary General in
strongly condemning North Korea for the
launch against relevant Security Council
resolutions Madam president colleagues
let us be clear this is not about
whether it was a satellite or not
this is not about if the launch failed
or not
this is about yet another violation of
the resolutions of this Council
the launch uses ballistic missile
technology which this Council has
prohibited in order to stop North
Korea's unlawful development of nuclear
weapons
and their means of delivery
space launched Vehicles use use the
identical technology as ballistic
missiles which can mount nuclear
warheads
we are not discussing the peaceful use
of of outer space or legitimate security
concerned regardless of whether it is a
missile or military satellite and
regardless of whether it succeeds or
fails it is a violation of the council's
resolutions
what we should not Overlook is that
North Korea clearly states its intention
to violate the resolutions once again it
has announced that it will soon launch
another military reconnaissance
satellite after the failure
I ask all council members to join the
call of the Secretary General to seize
such Acts it is disrespectful of this
Council and the United Nations Charter
Madam president colleagues the last time
we gathered in this chamber to discuss
the North Korean non-proliferation file
I reminded fellow colleagues of North
Korea's five-year military plan
the plan includes
the launch of military reconnaissance
satellite
here's what we have been witnessing
first
North Korea's steady implementation of
the long Pursuit nuclear and missile
programs and Military satellite launch
being as part of them
second
continue to silence and the inaction by
the council against repeated violations
by North Korea
third North Korea taking full advantage
of the council's silence and inaction
argue that the council should not meet
they contend that the council should not
provoke North Korea and should instead
seek to ease tensions with that silence
and self-restraint would contribute to
calming the station this is simply wrong
as I have repeatedly said our Silence
has only encouraged and will continue to
encourage
rule blinkers to write the Playbook as
they like
what we all of us here are interested to
do by all the member states of the
United Nations is to fulfill our heavy
responsibility to maintain International
Peace and security and not to turn our
eyes away from violations of this
council's own resolutions
president colleagues let's not last but
not least it is also of great regret
that we see the North Korean regime
continue to spend huge resources on its
unlawful nuclear and missile programs
while sacrificing the welfare of people
in North Korea
if the money is spent on launching the
military satellite had been spent on the
people instead how many would have been
fed
again Japan is North Korea not to
conduct further launches and once again
urges North Korea to immediately and
fully comply with all relevant
resolutions and to engage in diplomacy
and accept the repeated offers of
dialogue I will search all council
members and the member states to join
the school I thank you madam president
I thank the representative of Japan for
their statement I give the floor to the
representative of Malta
president Malta strongly condemns the
Democratic People's Republic of Korea
attempted launch of a military satellite
that occurred on Thursday 31st May
these latest developments show that dprk
continues to develop and improve its
ballistic missile capabilities in open
Defiance of Security Council resolutions
these activities must stop at once
even though the tests conveyed last
Thursday failed it is important to
underline the fact that Security Council
resolutions do not distinguish between
successful launches and failed attempts
such actions remain a flagrant violation
and show a concerning pattern of
Reckless Behavior by dprk
undermining Global non-proliferation
efforts and advancing its programs
the dprk is constant and completes this
regard for its obligations on the
security Council resolutions undermines
International Peace and security it is
crucial that all the membership
especially members of the security
Council speak out and demonstrate that
such actions will never be accepted
president
Malta calls upon Pyongyang to completely
verifiably and irreversibly abandon its
nuclear and ballistic missiles programs
and to return to full compliance with
its obligations under the npt as a
non-nuclear weapon state
we urged the PRK to cooperate promptly
with the iaea in the full and effective
implementation of the agency
comprehensive safeguards including all
necessary safeguards activities provided
for in the safeguards agreement we also
urge the dprk to sign and ratify the
comprehensive Test Ban Treaty
motor regrets that the council stands
Frozen regarding the responses to any of
the ICBM launches witnessed over the
past year
in this regard Malta recalls the
security Council resolution 2397 to
remind that we have the duty to take
action to maintain Regional and
International Peace and security
doing nothing or not reacting to these
unlawful actions of dprk would mean
normalizing violations in the face of
this Council it would mean accepting
that we are powerless to react to
proliferation crisis around the globe
president motor's concern for the
humanitarian situation faced by the dprk
population continues the dprk's blatant
violations of international law divert
resources from its people prevent its
Economic Development and undermine the
welfare of its population
Malta calls on the dprk to Faithfully
engage with the UN and international
humanitarian system as well as to enable
and facilitate humanitarian assistance
to reach those in greatest needs across
the country
in conclusion
I reiterate that everyone at this table
has a shared objective peace and the
denuclearization of the Korean Peninsula
divisions and inaction among the members
of the security Council will only push
us away from fulfilling our duty at the
same time motor calls on the dprk to
seize all actions that raise tensions
and instead choose the path of dialogue
thank you
I thank the representative of Malta for
their statement I now give the floor to
the representative of France
[Music]
Madam president
foreign
[Music]
the implementation of the security
Council resolutions
the evasion of sanctions I thank you
I thank the representative of France for
their statement and I give the floor to
the representative of Ghana
I thank you for giving me the floor
modern president I also thank USG
Rosemary di Carlo for a briefing to the
council and welcome the participation of
the permanent representative of the
Republic of Korea
Madam president Ghana is Gravely
concerned by the dprk's launch of a
military satellite on 31st May 2023 in
contravention of multiple Security
Council resolutions
we deployed the dprk's latest actions
call on the dprk to fully comply with
its International obligations under all
relevant Security Council resolutions
and take immediate and concrete steps to
de-escalate tensions on the Korean
Peninsula by refraining from further
launches with ballistic missile
technology
modern president the launch of a
military satellite is yet another
disturbing confirmation of the dramatic
acceleration of the DPR case weapons
program
it is also a warring reflection of the
DPR case resolved to accomplish its 2023
strategic goals set out at the six
plenary meeting of the 8th Central
Committee of the Workers Party of Korea
held in January this year
with its current launch the dprk has now
attempted to accomplish two of these key
strategic goals that is the launch of a
military satellite and the test of a
solid fuel ICBM
the 2023 final report of the 1718 panel
of expects makes it clear that the dprk
is working assiduously to accomplish its
third key strategic goal which is to
exponentially increase the production of
nuclear weapons particularly the mass
production of smaller tactical nuclear
weapons we therefore regret that in the
midst of all these rapidly changing
developments which threaten
International Peace and security the
council has not been unified in its
response despite the numerous meetings
held on the dprk this year and last year
we and we encourage all members of this
Council to embrace a unified and
different approach in order to obtain
different results with our engagement on
the dprk file in our common objectives
to achieve concrete progress in federals
of peace and security on the Korean
peninsula
modern President we believe that a
principled and pragmatic approach based
on diplomacy dialogue and Trust building
is needed to incrementally Foster
conditions that allow for constructive
engagement between the dprk and major
stakeholders on its weapons program
while different stakeholders may have
different interests on the situation in
the dprk it must be obvious that a
nuclearized Korean Peninsula is in no
one's interest
we must therefore work collaboratively
to strengthen the unity of the Council
on this matter and act Faithfully on
behalf of all member states who have
entrusted us with the powerful mandate
to maintain International Peace and
security I thank you for your kind
attention
I thank the representative of Ghana for
their statement and I give the floor to
the representative of Gabon
foreign
then we call for the strict respect of
the relative resolutions of this Council
Mr President as a state party
non-proliferation
treatment my country is against the
development use of the threat of use of
nuclear weapons
of nuclear risk um
[Music]
which could guarantee security and
peaceful coexistence in the region I
thank you I thank the representative of
Gabon and give the floor to the
representative of Switzerland
foreign
[Music]
these borders will be opened up to
facilities
to remain committed so that this Council
can find its common voice thank you I
thank the representative of Switzerland
for their statement I give the floor to
the representative of Mozambique
uh Mr President let them start by
wishing you and the United Arab Emirates
team a very successful month ahead at
the Helm of the security Council
be assured of mozambique's support and
collaboration whenever needed
let him also reiterate our
congratulation to Switzerland for an
accomplished stewardship of the council
during the month of May
I think under Secretary General Rosemary
DeCarlo
for her update I also acknowledge
the presence in this meeting of the
permanent representative of the Republic
of Korea Mr President
over years the situation in the Koreans
Peninsula has become very sensitive and
as CJ schools for concern
Mozambique reiterates the importance of
the new technologies towards improving
the quality of lives of human beings and
not for aggravating crisis and
instability
the launch of yet another settler
Satellite by the tprk although
unsuccessful confirms the Persistence of
tensions in the Korean Peninsula which
could lead to miscalculation and
confrontation
as well as to the erosion of compliance
to non-proliferation regimes in the
region
as we repeatedly stated before this
chamber
including during last briefing on the
issue in April Mozambique reiterates its
call to the dprk to abide by Security
Council resolutions and to cooperate in
de-escalating and already tense
situation
will remain also concerned by the lack
of progress and changes in the status
quo despite repeated meetings by the
council
Mr President
we call on the security Council to
fulfill its responsibilities by engaging
in efforts towards the resumption of
dialogue
diplomatic engagement and the window of
opportunity to persuade dprk to desist
from provocative act acts and return to
negotiating table should be considered
given the right intentions in the Korean
Peninsula as well as the fact that DPR
case is continuing to show resolve in
continuing to develop its Technical and
technological capabilities
Avenue shoe for the dialogues must be to
shoot and preserved
in conclusion we call on the council to
use its primary role and mandate in the
maintenance of International Peace and
security to encourage dialogue the
escalation and the search for diplomatic
Solutions I thank you
I thank the representative of Mozambique
for their statement
I give the floor to the representative
of Brazil
thank you Mr President
at the outset allow me to thank ussg
Rosemary DiCarlo for her informative
briefing
I welcome to this meeting the delegation
of the Republic of Korea
Mr President
Brazil deplores the use of political
missile of technology in the latest
launch of a rocket by the dprk on May
30th
while recognizing the right of all
countries to pursue peaceful space
programs Brazil also stresses the need
for the dprk to fully comply with all
its obligations under U.N security
Council resolutions and under
international law more broadly
according to several reports
this show Molina rocket one rocket used
similar engines to those used in liquid
field ICBM Watson 15 which represents a
clear violation of ob2 of resolution
2094 that prohibits the dprk from
conducting any further launches that use
ballistic missiles technology
the fact
that this time a pre-launch notice was
issued to the international Maritime
organization as means to mitigate risk
to civilian populations in the Republic
of Korea and Japan as well as Somali
time and air traffic in the region
however
such notification does not set aside the
legality of the latest launch
Mr President
the alarm raised by this launch is yet
another illustration of the dangerous
state of this file where miscalculation
by any party could have drastic
consequences
the latest mobilization of military
assets for possible missile intercepts
even if defensive in nature shows how
the region stands on a hair trigger
tensions must be dialed down
Brazil will continue to make all efforts
to promote engagement that can
contribute to lowering tensions and
reducing and reducing the risks of
escalation
as we have said before dialogue is
important among friends but it's
essential among Rivals we continue to be
convinced that engagement not isolation
remains our best path towards a Korean
Peninsula that's peaceful stable and
free of nuclear weapons and I thank you
I thank the representative of Brazil for
their statement and I give the floor to
the representative of China
Mr President
featuring
escalation still made confrontation and
escalation
there were moments of Hope on issue
including the 1994 agreed Frameworks
joint statement by six parts
and the 2018 Singapore declaration
through those times the dprk actively
engaged in dialogue with the US and
generally complied
the U.S failed to abide by the
principles
of sanctions
and amidst opportunity to resolve the
issue in recent years
into its indo-pacific strategies it's
deterrence and even planning to send
strategic nucleations
the U.S approach represents a disregard
for the concerns of other countries and
it's
geopolitical self-interest through which
it is bent on exploiting the issue on
the peninsula such practices by the U.S
are filled with cold war mentality only
served to provoke block confrontations
security interests of other countries to
the goal of maintaining peace and
stability and promoting the
nuclearization of the peninsula
the current situation
start with tension fragility complexity
for all parties to maintain calm and
restraint avoid virtual provocation and
prevent the situation
the more so the more important it is
some countries have repeatedly included
that the security Council must not
remain indifference
Mutual trust and unity
uranium to non-nuclear weapon states
which is a typical events such a
cooperation does nothing but undermine
the global non-proliferation regime
stock arms race
and process of the peninsula and thus my
Must Be Stopped seriously thank you Mr
President
I thank the representative of China for
their statement I give the floor to the
representative of the Russian Federation
[Music]
should have an impartial and objective
stance
negative
[Music]
foreign
continue following a vicious circle
[Music]
global stability
in the agreements
[Music]
provocation of an arms race
foreign
[Music]
which remains on the table I thank you
for your attention
I thank the representative of the
Russian Federation for their statement
I shall now make a statement in my
capacity as the representative of the
United Arab Emirates
I thank under Secretary General De Carlo
for her informative briefing and we
welcome the participation of the
Republic of Korea in today's meeting the
UAE joins the Secretary General in his
strong condemnation of the military
satellite launched by the dprk these
events are of grave concern
though the satellite launch rocket
failed on 31st May local time dprk
officials have vowed to undertake a
second launch as soon as possible
we reiterate that any launch by the dprk
using ballistic missile technology has
been prohibited by the security Council
and we strongly urge them to desist from
their unlawful dangerous and provocative
activities
the UAE would like to emphasize the
following points regarding this latest
launch
first civilians cannot continue to be at
the mercy of the ongoing threats we note
that some Advance warning of the
intended satellite launch was provided
on this most recent occasion this may
have reduced risks to neighboring
countries to some degree but such
warnings neither legitimize nor minimize
the illegal illegality of the dprk's
launch the fear and danger imposed on
the people of the Republic of Korea and
Japan as a result of these actions is
unacceptable and unjustifiable we stand
in solidarity with the governments and
people of these countries and The Wider
region
second we reiterate reiterate our call
for the dprk to comply with Security
Council resolutions and international
law the UAE recognizes that satellites
can be used by States for peaceful
purposes however due to past actions the
council has prohibited the dprk from any
launchers using ballistic missile
technology regardless of its goal
because such efforts launched or
launches may help accelerate its illegal
wmd program
reporting suggests that the objective of
this most recent launch was to put the
dprk's first military reconnaissance
satellite into orbit we are reminded of
the Pledge the country's leader has made
to accelerate its so-called five-year
military plan too in the words of the
dprk
fight a war at the highest level
this is of great concern considering the
nuclear weapons and InterContinental
capabilities which the dprk has been
developing at PACE
we call on the dprk to return to
diplomacy and dialogue for talks in any
format enacting a complete verifiable
and irreversible path to
denuclearization including a return to
the non-proliferation treaty without
delay must be the way forward for the
dprk and the International Community
the iaea's role in verifying these
objectives is critical the dprk should
adhere to the iaea's safeguards and
allow for the agency's inspectors to
return to the country
third the UAE remains deeply troubled by
the humanitarian situation in the dprk
reports of a worsening food shortage
coupled with severe weather conditions
and the country's decision to keep its
borders closed to humanitarian
organizations is estimated to put as
much as 60 percent of the dprk
population at grave risk of malnutrition
this has purportedly increased by 20 in
the last three years
the dprk has acknowledged the need for
humanitarian assistance but has not
created an enabling environment for Aid
delivery including by not allowing U.N
Personnel to return to the country
ultimately it is the people of the dprk
who are suffering and we urge the
government to invite humanitarian
organizations back to the country to
provide life-saving humanitarian
assistance
it is the people of the dprk who require
the council support at this time to
conclude we recall that when the council
was United on this issue in the past it
was capable of curbing the dprk's
unlawful pursuit of nuclear weapons the
UAE urges the council to find such Unity
again and speak with one voice to
address this situation thank you
I resume my function as president of the
council
the representative of the United States
has asked for the floor to make a
further statement I give him the floor
thank you madam president I apologize
for taking the floor and I promise not
to be very long in responding to a few
of these charges I'd first like to note
uh that I found interesting that the
representative the Chinese delegation
did not at any point condemn this uh
dprk space launch which again is in
violation of multiple U.N security
Council resolutions
uh there was a reference about dprk
adhering to agreements uh particularly
the framework agreement from the early
90s I think what was interesting about
that time period was that uh while dprk
was supposedly adhering uh to this
agreement it was also in the process of
developing a clandestine uranium
enrichment program so so much for
adherence to that agreement uh there was
a reference to the Washington
declaration I'd just be very clear that
the Washington Declaration was a
response is a response to dprk's
destabilizing activities with regard to
its ballistic missile and nuclear
weapons programs uh it's not the other
way around it's to be clear
um
this is not an issue of of two sides
here in the security Council there's one
party that has been sanctioned by the
security Council
that's the dprk
uh there was a reference to the Chinese
and Russian draft resolution that would
ease sanctions on dprk it's hard to
imagine that we should ease sanctions on
dprk while it continues this
destabilizing behavior and think about
the message that sends to the world that
you can go ahead and just willfully
violate U.N security Council resolutions
and yet you're going to be rewarded so I
think we have to really think very
seriously about that I'd also like to
emphasize that in any of our deterrence
cooperation with the ROK the United
States nor might I add the ROK neither
is in violation of the nuclear not
proliferation treaty just want to be
very clear about that my last Point
um
in terms of U.S willingness to engage
the dprk and serious seriousness about
engaging dprk we have said on many many
occasions we are prepared to have an
unconditional dialogue with the dprk to
try to deal with our differences as you
all know the dprk has rejected our
interventions on many occasions let me
stop there thank you madam president I
thank the representative of the United
States for their statement
the representative of China has asked
for the floor to make a further
statement I give them the floor
United States
I need to make a response I would try to
be fine as I have mentioned earlier
um
it's not like all the buildings are on
the other side or the problems
the peace
and there has been long-standing
mistrust between the two countries
I have also mentioned
there has been some brighter moments in
the past
third regarding Washington technology
and
um
I think we all are clear if U.S
continues
[Music]
conditions for that thank you
I thank the representative of China for
their statement I now give the floor to
the representative of the Republic of
Korea
thank you madam president
I'd like to begin by thanking you for
conveying this important meeting of the
security Council
my gratitude also goes to me the
Rosemary Carlo for her briefing
the Republic of Korea condemns in the
strongest possible terms the tprk is the
so-called military reconnaissance
satellite on May 31st local time
the dprk regime has been completely
obsessed with the launching a military
reconnaissance satellite ever since it
unveiled its five-year military
development plan in 2021.
the dprk leader
visited its National Aerospace
development Administration which is on
Security Council sanctions list in April
and May and personally approved its
launch
this palpable demonstrates that the dbrk
and its few supporters claim that jprk
provocations were triggered by RK US
military exercises or any moves to
strengthen the alliance in the face of
growing dprk threats is not consistent
to read effects
tprk is doing what it wants according to
its own playable
after the launch the dprk foreign
Ministry mocked and condemned the
Secretary General
for his statement on this yesterday
Leader's sister issued a statement to
justify their unlawful action by
claiming its Sovereign right to use
space and totally disregarding this
Council
now while reaffirming their plan to
launch another one until it succeeds she
even said I quote the far-fetched logic
that only the dprk is not allowed to
allow to launch a satellite by security
resolutions is clearly wrong and against
alike end of quote
I came across a fitting analogy the
other day as a counter argument that a
knife is just a kitchen utensil
for ordinary people but it is a little
weapon
for criminals
Madam president any launch using
ballistic missile technology by the dprk
is explicitly prohibited by multiple
skilled Council resolutions
the reason is simple the dprk is the
first and the only case that has abused
the npt regime and then open it
developed nuclear weapons and their
Delivery Systems
here I do not need to remind you all
that the security Council unanimously
without any objection or abstention
adopted resolution 2087 in January 2013
to respond to dprk's so-called Huang
myongsong-3 satellite launch
regardless of whether it succeeded or
not and whatever time Pyongyang is using
to describe it there is no doubt that
this launch constitutes a flagrant
violation of skilled Council resolutions
the launch does not fall into the
category of peaceful use of outer space
launch Vehicles incorporate almost
identical Technologies with those used
in ballistic missiles such as
multi-stage rockets and guidance
navigation and control systems
place a nuclear warhead instead of a
satellite on a space launch a vehicle
and you end up with a nuclear weapon
security comes resolution 20 to 70 which
was adopted unanimously again after the
dprk the so-called Huang myongsang 4
satellite launched in February 2016 also
made it abundantly clear that this
launch use the ballistic missile
technology and therefore it was
prohibited
Madam president this Council must act
with one strong voice the security
Council should not remain silent on the
DPR case failed launch
the council has restrained from taking
substantial measures on the DPR case
failed launches in the past
however the dprk learns and advances its
wmd program based on these failed
launches
the council's in action not only
emboldened Pyongyang but also misguised
the International Community into
accepting that the council will stand by
idly and wait for the dprk's successful
launch the before it seriously responds
even as we speak today the dprk is
buying time to further Advance its
unlawful nuclear and missile programs
according to its own plan
taking full advantage of the paralyzed
Security Council and weakened
implementation of skilled counsel
sanctions
in this slide I'd like to underline the
need to strengthen our cooperation to
cut off the dprk's revenue sources for
its wmd programs
the dprk profits massively from its
malicious cyber activities and overseas
I.T workers with forged identities based
all around the world
which have a seriously destabilizing
effect on International Peace and
security the security Council should do
more to prevent and counter this
pressing matter
some argue their sanctions are
ineffective ineffective to address the
dprk's wmd programs however the
sanctions have been curbing illicit
revenue streams over the dprk to some
degree thus far
sanctions must be thoroughly implemented
by all including all of the members of
this Council in order to be more
effective
Madam present it is simply appalling to
witness the dprk regime obsessively
spending enormous amounts of money and
resources on its wmd program while its
own people persistently suffer from
deteriorating short food shortages as
well as gross and systematic human
rights abuses
The dprk's Reckless pursuit of a growing
nuclear Arsenal in total disregard of
international obligations and
its totalitarian control of its own
people are indeed the two sides of the
same coin
my delegation urges all counts members
to support the Revival of Security
Council public meetings on the dprk
human rights situation with which the
council remains deceased
in concluding the Republic of Korea
would like to reiterate that the door
for dialogue and negotiation remains
wide open despite the dprk's
intensifying provocations and threats
we strongly urge the dprk once again to
cease further escalatory actions to
fulfill its International obligations
and return to diplomacy
I thank you Mr Madam president
I thank the representative of the
Republic of Korea for their statement
there are no more names inscribed in the
list of speakers the meeting is
adjourned